very well allow me to tell you about a
jewel oh no is this one of the Echoes
where you get to relive a memory I
didn't witness it myself of course but I
have friends hung in the ministry who
say it was most epic
portrait story
I need him why would I need a moment
I wouldn't have started talking to you
oh my gosh let's go yes
dude
this moment is so epic
do we get to actually play this oh we do
drag the orb of water to Voldemort's
location
they actually have the orb of water
spell
oh my gosh the orb of water moves when
you do
okay
oh dude that's cool
is that the only spell we have though
oh I probably need to get rid of that
don't I oh oh no it didn't do anything
he just tried to cast AK on us
I don't like that
no double door move
Dumbledore you gotta get out of the way
he's casting AK on us left and right
orb of water
there we go there we go there we go
Voldemort calm down dude
oh my gosh Voldemort
he's just casting it over and over
he is beating us right now though
can I actually I I thought I had it
right on this guy
there we go okay I guess I just missed
before
dude's got Dementors
pure totem locomotor someone's
practically indestructible stone statues
yeah we definitely need some help
there we go Dumbledore show your
Transfiguration skills
baby antibody and opal eye summons a
baby dragon that breathes fire
yeah yeah let's do it
thunderstorm causes a Thunderbird
okay now we're seeing the powerful
spells we got the we got the big time
Wizards in Action here thunderstorm
causes a Thunderbird to strike a random
opponent with lightning okay it's a
random Target
oh so it just yeah we don't know who
it's gonna hit
that is amazing
I cannot believe Voldemort just
repeatedly
and then you got Dumbledore all of
Walter
orb of water
dude Voldemort bringing out the
werewolves now
oh yeah we need we need our
let's put these guys right here
I mean it's AK
a
I think we were about to find out
I like these statues man
practically indestructible they said
come on we need that to hit Voldemort
darn it
Lots going on on screen right now
yeah
all right we're ahead of him now we're
ahead
dude it's kind of crazy this is a mobile
game
mobile game
I don't know man maybe mobile games have
improved a lot I don't I don't play a
lot of mobile games but
this is crazy impressive I feel like
we got the epic music going to
try complete we got him
let's go
GG's Dumbledore